we're one jump ahead of the gossip about
Disney's new Aladdin are you ready to
see all your favorite characters in
their live-action forms keep watching
for the first look at Aladdin you don't
want to go for a ride do you
Aladdin from riffraff and street rat to
Prince Ali Ababwa there's one thing that
Aladdin stole from everyone back in the
90s he stole our hearts you know this
story Aladdin is a poor kid off the
streets in mythical Agrabah he's got to
eat to live but also has to steal to eat
it's turned him into something of a
menace his only friend is a monkey named
Abu he falls in love with princess
jasmine but he cannot marry her because
he's not a prince he's sent to steal a
lamp from the Cave of Wonders inside is
a genie who helps him become a prince
the actor who plays Aladdin in the new
movie has a pretty big role to fill
Aladdin is iconic but we think they did
a great job casting Meena Masood as the
infamous street urchin check out this
shot of the human version of Aladdin
what do you think does he look like the
original cartoon character we think it's
a pretty close match Meena Massoud
definitely has some Aladdin vibe but
there are some pretty big costume
changes
Aladdin definitely isn't wearing the
iconic purple vest and it's actually
wearing a shirt that's probably a lot
more practical in the desert Sun to be
honest
who is this Mena guy anyway Meena
Massoud is an Egyptian Canadian actor
he's been on several television shows
like the 99 and open-heart recently he
was in the Tom Clancy's Jack Ryan show
and he's been one busy actor he has five
films coming out in 2019 we're so
excited to see what he brings to the
legendary character of Disney he has
said in interviews that he got really
close to Will Smith who plays Jeannie
their relationship is going to make
their on-screen chemistry amazing are
you excited to see Mina play Aladdin
jasmine one of the biggest changes
between the original film and the new
live-action version is princess
Jasmine's character back in 1992 jasmine
was pretty revolutionary for a disney
princess she was one of the first
princesses to be considered a stronger
feminist influence and with the street
rats not your concern
do as I command release him in the
original her father the Sultan was
trying to set her up with any Prince
just to marry her off because it was
expected
but Jazmin was not about that life she
sabotage all the princes she met because
she wanted to choose her own love she
even tried to run away and disguised
herself as a peasant girl which is where
she first met Aladdin the new movie is
taking Jasmine's independence one step
further she isn't just a princess who
sits down and lets her father ruled she
cares about her people and she is
outspoken AF she's intelligent and
strong in the movie we'll see her going
from asking for what she wants - just
taking it yes honey we're so excited to
see this character art and let's talk
about the actress playing Jasmine forget
princess Naomi Scott is more like a
queen this English actress is only 25
years old and she is already making
waves she starred in some pretty intense
action and drama roles you probably
recognise her as the pink Power Ranger
from the 2017 movie and she's one of the
Charlie's Angels in the new movie that
debuts later this year and just look at
her rocking the new costumes no not that
one gone is the old school blue harem
outfit of the 90s jasmine looks like a
princess now her costumes are vibrant
and elaborate and they're much less
revealing than our animated counterpart
it's part of the process of making
jasmine so much more than just a
princess who has to get married some
things are definitely staying the same
though jasmine will still have her pet
tiger Raja we're excited to see Naomi
Scott as Jasmine naomi has talked about
how important it was as a child to see a
princess that looked like her now the
English Indian actress can bring that
same representation to a whole new
generation that's pretty amazing if you
ask us genie
the original genie is something of a
legend you'll always be a prince to me
it was right when he told Aladdin that
he ain't never had a friend like this
big blue lamp dwelling spirit in the
1992 film genie was played by comic
legend Robin Williams and that role
remained one of his best he was more or
less the star of the movie
sadly Robin Williams passed away
tragically a few years ago leaving the
world a little less funny people were
really concerned about who could fill
these giant Genie shoes when the casting
decision was announced there was a lot
of debate but from what we've heard Will
Smith is going to bring some fresh new
flavor to the beloved care
fresh get it but he's also trying to pay
homage to the comedic genius of Robin
Williams you might think Smith is a
strange choice to play a goofy genie
after all he's known for dramas like
pursuit of happiness and action films
like bad boys but he's no stranger to
comedy he was the star of The Fresh
Prince of bel-air which is one of the
funniest sitcoms ever he's made it clear
that he isn't trying to rip off Robin
Williams genie either the original genie
was basically an exaggerated version of
Williams Smith is trying to do the same
while accepting that he's a different
person than Williams he's pulling from
his Fresh Prince days and other iconic
roles like men in black he's adding a
flair for fashion and a bit of an ego
and instead of the showtune vibe of the
original he's adding some unique hip-hop
flavor to the music the first photos of
genie were released in December of 2018
and fans noticed that something was
missing something very big and blue Will
Smith's genie was not blue at all if you
outraged but Smith has promised that
he'll be blue in the movie poof the
genie has some other aesthetic changes
he's wearing some amazing costumes and
is loaded with bling but he still got
the iconic shaved head with a pony tail
on top we're pretty sure only Will Smith
could rock this look this Genie looks
way more human than the animated version
we know we know he's supposed to be blue
but he just looks a lot more solid than
the more spirit like Robin Williams
genie what do you think about the
casting choice for genie we're excited
to see how this turns out we definitely
love Will Smith Abu Jafar in the Sultan
Aladdin has a ton of amazing characters
and we're excited to see how they're
brought to life in the remake one fan
favorite is Abu Aladdin's pet monkey
she was in trouble he's a source of
comic relief in the 1992 animated film
and we can expect him to serve the same
role in the new movie while Aladdin
steals to survive Abu is quite the
little thief in fact in the original
it's his fault that the Cave of Wonders
starts collapsing he just couldn't keep
his little monkey fingers to himself
you'll be happy to know that Abu is back
in the new movie and he's totes adorbs
seriously look at that little face here
we see him looking at something in awe
inside the Cave of Wonders he may be
cute but he still looks like he knows
how to monkey around Jafar is one of the
most evil Disney villains of all time
he's the grand Weiser which is basically
the Sultan's right-hand man and this guy
is after power he schemes and does
whatever it takes to get his way in the
original he recruits Aladdin to steal
the lamp from the Cave of Wonders
eventually he gets his hands on it and
usurped power from the Sultan our first
look at Defarge shows him looking really
evil he's dressed in reds and golds and
his whole demeanor just reeks of villain
he's also holding the lamp in the photo
so we know at least that part of the
story is the same Jafar is played by
Marwan Ken's re he was in the 2017
version of the mummy and Murder on the
Orient and we're excited to see a lot
more of him there's no word yet on
whether Yago Jafar sassy parrot will be
in the new movie
but since Rajah the tiger and Abu the
monkey are returning we hope we see Iago
we haven't seen much of the new Sultan
but we do get a quick glimpse in a shot
with Princess Jasmine
in the original the Sultan is a short
funny little man he doesn't seem like a
great leader and is determined to marry
off his daughter this still shot from
the new movie shows him looking a lot
more serious than his animated
counterpart he's got an updated costume
and he looks like he's got a tough
relationship with jasmine the Sultan is
played by Naveed negev on he is best
known for his role as a terrorist leader
from the show homeland he's an amazing
actor so we know he'll do a great job in
the movie the new character there's a
brand new character in this movie fans
of Saturday Night Live will be thrilled
to see a familiar face Nasim pedrad will
play Dalia Jasmine's handmaiden and best
friend a princess would not be totally
isolated
the Arabian Kingdom even if agra buys a
made-up place it makes sense that
jasmine would have other women around
and Dahlia is also the bestie that is
there for her when things get tough
Naomi Scott and Nasim pedrad are really
close friends in real life it was
important to the actresses that they
show a realistic female friendship after
all strong women need other strong women
to support them Nasim is a talented and
hilarious actress Dalia is love for
Jazmin is really going to come across in
the new movie and we need to see that
the more we see women lifting other
women up the better
who is the Dalia to your Jazmin let us
know in the comments section below
production details people were shocked
when Disney announced that Guy Ritchie
was directing the new Aladdin he's an
amazing director but he isn't really
known for kids movies he's better known
for things like snatch and Lock Stock
and Two Smoking Barrels so what drew
Richey to this movie it turns out he was
pumped about directing a kids movie he
thinks his skills with action and drama
will lend a hot new lens to the classic
film but he's also careful not to get
rid of the nostalgia feelings Jeannie
I'm gonna miss you it's definitely going
to be an interesting movie Ritchie faced
a unique challenge with this movie a lot
of people were concerned that Disney
would ignore the rich Middle Eastern
heritage of the story but the director
has made this one of the most diverse
Disney films ever the actors represent
countries like Iran Tunisia Egypt and
India they're also Canadian American and
Dutch that's a lot of countries Ritchie
also had cultural advisors helping him
every step of the way
Agrippa is a fictional Kingdom but it
does represent the beautiful cities of
early Arabia Ritchie and his team first
considered using the beautiful desert
city of Morocco to film the movie but he
didn't want to be limited they used
Morocco Persia and Turkey for
inspiration along with other cultures
but they actually built a set in England
they built it totally from scratch which
gave them a lot more creative freedom
it's going to be one visually appealing
film they filmed the desert scenes in
the desert though that part is real and
check out the gorgeous Cave of Wonders
set from the teaser trailer it looks
epic
no wonder Abu looked so amazed as far as
music goes we can expect some new takes
on the classic songs we know Will Smith
is bring
a little hip-hop did the genie songs
there's also new music Jasmine gets a
solo song Alan Menken is back as the
composer which is great he composed all
those amazing Disney songs from the 90s
he's also joined by songwriters bench
press Eck and Justin Paul who worked on
the soundtrack for La Valle and the new
music will be lit Aladdin drops on May
24th 2019 we cannot wait we wish we
could rub a magic lamp and ask for the
movie to come out super if you had a
genie to grant you three wishes what
would they be sound off in the comments
and that's all the deets about the new
Aladdin movie you don't need a magic
lamp for more awesome videos just click
subscribe see you next time
[Music]